okay hi everybody Welcome to the second
day of the boot camp so in the next two
talks are going to be by we know and to
give us an introduction to high
dimensional expanders and tell you all
about it so take it away
thank you doll and hi everyone I hope
you are having a great time at Simon's
and at the boot camp and I hope to come
join you uh sorry I'm not there right
now but I'm sure you're gonna have a a
great time so uh try not to ruin it let
me start I'm gonna talk about high
dimensional expanders so uh the first
definition I must start with is
definition of just uh expanders in
graphs so you know expander graphs are
such a fundamental object in computer
science and actually in many many areas
in mathematics and I'm not gonna
uh spend time saying how useful and
important they are let's just say the
definition that we will use here I
assume you've all seen many other
definitions and relations
between them uh for us a graph is going
to be called the Lambda spectral
expander
if when I look at a sub G I have this
notation here a sub G is supposed to be
the adjacency Matrix
of the graph but normalize so you should
think of it maybe as like the random
walk Matrix of the graph a sub G is
supposed is uh going to be similar in
the spectral Norm to The adjacency
Matrix 1 over n times J that's the
adjacency Matrix of the complete graph
with self loops
and basically it says that a random walk
on our graph which is sparse typically
is going to behave if you view it
actually as if you're just walking from
vertex to vertex randomly choosing the
next vertex independently of what
happened before
this is a kind of a good way to think
about an expander is that it it really
approximate it's a sparse graph but it
approximates the complete graph up to
this
error term of Lambda Lambda is abound on
the second largest eigenvalue and we
actually have two variants of this
definition
one-sided and two-sided uh one-sided is
when all the eigenvalues except for the
top eigenvalue so I have them here are
bounded by Lambda so Lambda 2 is bounded
by Lambda and two-sided is where all the
eigenvalues from Lambda n to Lambda 2
are between minus Lambda and Lambda so
that's a stronger bound it's a two-sided
and a useful way to think of the
definition of expansion is that when you
take the the expectation over oops
expectation over a random Edge and you
look at f u times FV
and you compare it to the same kind of
form except now u and v are completely
independent then these two expectations
are similar and their difference is no
more than Lambda
okay
and I guess I included here also the
one-sided definition
this says that a minus J is bounded by
Lambda I in the semi-definite order
okay so that's the definition of an
expander it really says that the graph
is very well connected and I'm not going
to give motivation assuming that we've
all seen these things and let me move
straight to defining expansion in higher
Dimensions so a higher dimensional graph
would typically be a hypergraph and
we're going to use the definition of
simplicial complex which we can view as
a hypograph that is downwards closed and
it's kind of more convenient to work
with so let's see what the definition is
we're looking at a simplicial complex
which has a set a vertices x0 and then a
set of edges X1 and so on a set of D
phase is x sub d
and the D phase is just a set of D plus
one vertices
and the property of a simplicial complex
is that if you have some face in x s
then if T is some subset of s t must
also be next so in other words you have
a collection of D plus one sets and
every subset of them is also included in
your in your simplicial complex it's
like a hypergraph where you close
downwards and we will soon say why we
like this downwards close your property
so first let's just look at the picture
of an example a simplicial complex so
here we have a graph on six vertices so
we have six vertices in maybe seven
edges and we also have something new
which is the triangle so we have here x0
are the vertices X1 or the edges this is
just as usual and X2 are just a
collection of sets of three elements so
one two three two three four and four
five six these are the so-called
triangles or two faces
and this is a simplicial complex and now
I want to come to the first definition
that's kind of new and interesting and
this is the definition of a link
so in a simplicial complex there is this
notion of a link which is like a
neighborhood of a face so if you have a
face V you can think of v as a Vertex
but more generally it can be a face of
the larger dimension
then the link is obtained by looking at
all the faces that are that contain this
V so all the faces above the
okay you look at all the faces s in your
complex that contain v and then the link
is comprised of these faces but when you
remove V from them
okay since you're a in a simplicial
complex setting you know that if s is in
the complex then s minus V is actually
also in the complex so this happens to
also be a face in the original
complex X okay let's look at an example
pertaining to the complex that we have a
picture here so let's look at the link
of the vertex three here's the vertex
three
I need to look at all the faces that
contain three so I have here this Edge
this Edge and this Edge
and for each of them I need to remove
three from them so I end up with these
three vertices
and I also need to look at all the
triangles that contains very so I have
this triangle when I remove three from
it I get this Edge and from this
triangle when I remove three I get this
Edge so all in all this is the graph
that I get the vertices are the
neighbors of the vertex three one two
and four and the edges are the are the
result of taking the triangles and
removing our vertex from from them so
what's the link of the Vertex 4 in this
in this example again I I have a Vertex
for every neighbor and I have two
triangles so it's going to give me two
edges and this is exactly the length and
notice that in this case the link
of the vertex 3 is connected but the
link of the Vertex 4 is actually not
connected so notice that we had a two
dimensional complex and now we looked at
the link and now the link itself is a
one-dimensional complex so always the
link of a Vertex is going to have one
dimension less and if you look at the
link of a higher dimensional face then
the dimension will decrease
proportionally
okay so now that we have defined the
links we are ready to give a definition
of a high dimensional expander
no I'm gonna say that this definition is
not possibly the first definition that
comes to mind
and really uh for many years people have
studied various ways to Define expansion
of hypergraphs and there's many other
definitions that are useful in in other
settings but kind of in this area uh I'm
gonna give today two definitions this
one in a random mock definition and
you'll see
uh there maybe not the first that come
to mind but they're still kind of
powerful
okay so let's see what the definition is
so definition is going to talk about
what happens in the links we're going to
say that uh complex three-dimensional
complex X is a Lambda link expander
if for every face for every face in in
our complex whose Dimension is
two below the top Dimension or even
smaller so if the complex is D
dimensional we only look at V's whose
Dimension is D minus two or less
and then once you fix this face Savvy
you look at the link of the X of V which
we just defined
and X of V can be a you know a higher
dimensional complex it's not necessarily
a graph but I can look at the vertices
of x sub V this is denoted x v 0. so
these are basically just the neighbors
of v and the edges of x sub V these are
basically the pairs of neighbors of V
that participate in a triangle with p
okay so this gives me a graph this is
called the one skeleton of the link so
again I look at the face V I look at
this neighborhood of v and the kind of
the one skeleton of what's around V and
I require that this graph itself is a
Lambda expander
this is the definition
and in this case sometimes people call
this Lambda spectral a high dimensional
expander or link expander
and this is uh
these are the names so far
and let me say that this definition
um
came up who kind of was developed uh in
parallel with the development of this
Theory and I think mainly it was
developed in the sequence of works by
Kaufman and lubotsky and kashidan and
jayavra where they actually looked at
this very specific simplicial complex
called the lsv complex which I talk
about soon
and they were trying to understand that
complex and it's a very the definition
of this complex is very difficult
because it's defined by quotients of
something
and the way they managed to get a handle
on that complex is by looking at the
leaks and understanding the links and
then they managed to prove really
wonderful properties about this complex
and that's how this definition kind of
arose because it it was enough to
require that the links satisfy these
properties and I forgot to say the
complex needs to be connected
and just being connected and having the
links being a good spectral expanders is
already enough for for a lot and we'll
see that now
so that's the origin of this definition
in order to appreciate this definition I
think the best thing for us to do is to
look at a few examples of a high
dimensional expanders and see how they
behave with respect to this definition
Okay so
in graphs the model expander well people
will tell you that a random graph is the
model expander but let me say that the
model expander is actually the complete
graph the reason we like it less is
because it then on the other hand lens
it's really the most connected graph so
similarly we have
a special complex you have a graph of n
if this is and then
possible I faces so you take all
processes two edges all possible end
choose three try one two seven d
[Music]
think of the
person scheme is supposed to be
names
and it's the same is same
size you know P times and silicone
conflicts
and it's easy to when you think about it
to see that things
contests are just the complete complex
one we wouldn't Less in one
dimensionless
okay here's another non-example a random
complex so for graphs we know that a
random our regular graph is actually a
fantastic expander and there's still
many open questions trying to construct
explicitly a graphs that have some
properties of random graphs in this
Theory the situation is different and we
don't actually have a random model for a
sparse High dimensional expander not
even for Dimension two so once you go
above graphs already the random Theory
kind of doesn't have enough power and
let's look at two examples if you choose
edges each one with probability p
then if you take P small enough to
consider this to be sparse you'll not
get any triangles
you can also try to say no I'm going to
choose triangles at random and just put
them in my graph you can do that but
then if you look at the vertex
and you look at its link so this vertex
participates in some number of triangles
but each of these triangles will kind of
be disconnected
and it will only be connected if you
choose many many triangles so there is
some threshold if you raise P to be
large enough this will actually be a
good expander but definitely not if you
want constant degree
So Random graphs are not going to be
very helpful for this Theory random
complexes
here's another example that's uh maybe
not so interesting but it's a good
warm-up for the one after and this is
the D plus one apartheid complex
complete sorry D plus one partite
complete complex here what we have is a
collection of subsets of vertices each
of size n
and disjoint and then the faces are
going to be D plus one tuples where you
choose one vertex from each from each
set from each color
okay so you have your D plus one colors
and you choose one vertex from each
color and I only need to tell you what
the top faces are because then you do
downwards closure so you take all
subsets of these faces and you get a a
simplicial complex
so let's uh notice that
each phase corresponds to a d plus one
Tuple I wrote it here V 0 up to VD in N
to the D plus one so it's another way to
represent tuples of elements in
in n okay and let's think what does a
link look like so if I choose some
vertex V in some whoops in some
okay
colors
and hail it we cannot hear you
okay
all right
foreign
yes many times
Yuri can you mute the iPad audio
I'm thinking about it thinking about it
thinking about it
okay I had to disconnect the audio and I
I think I did it now sorry about that
and I was good
okay so how far uh
um how far back should I go
you started explaining the complete D
plus one partite complex
ah the host stopped the video
okay uh complete different type complex
thank you wrote something the links okay
all right so suppose I have a vertex in
some color class J
I
okay
all right I have a vertex in some color
class J and I look at the link so I need
to basically look at all the faces
containing this vertex
who are they well basically I need to
choose a Vertex from every other color
class so I have one fewer colors and I
have still n vertices in each one
so I get a complete
departite complex on the same all the
remaining color classes basically
and you can see that the the skeleton of
this graph is like a a bunch of the
colors and between each pair there's a
complete bipartite graph so this is a
very good expander so we would
definitely call this a high dimensional
expander
okay
now uh moving on to something that's a
bit more interesting this is the
spherical building
okay I hope we're together still okay
that's good
all right so the spherical building uh
maybe it will look a bit strange but we
really uh like it because hey it's easy
to describe and B it is a component in
this
ramanujan complexes that I told you
about before so somehow it's an
important
high-dimensional expander
let's see what it is so you fix some
finite field fq of your choice and you
fix some parameter D it's the dimension
and then your vertices are going to be
all linear subspaces
uh of the vector space f to the D plus
2. okay now I'm not specifying a
dimension so we're going to take all
linear subspaces of all possible
dimensions and actually the vertices
come with colors so a vertex of color I
or type I if you want is a linear
Subspace of Dimension I and we let I
range from 1 to D plus one these are all
the non-trivial subspaces of f to the D
Plus 2. okay and all of these are just
considered vertices they're not higher
dimensional faces all the different
linear subspaces and now what are the
faces the faces are chains of subspaces
okay Flags sometimes we call them the
chains are all possible tuples U1 U2 up
to u d plus one
such that u i is a linear space of
Dimension I and U1 is contained in U2 is
contained in u3 and so forth
so it's a chain of subspaces that's a
the face
so let's look at an example for D equals
one
I have F to the three and I have all
possible linear spaces there so
basically I have lines in Planes
so my vertices have two types either
lines or planes
and the edges are just pairs U on U2
where U1 is a line that is contained in
U2 there is a plane
okay so it's a bipartite graph it's just
a one-dimensional complex and it's the
you can think of it as the lines versus
planes the incidence graph sometimes but
people really like to call it the points
versus lines
graph in projective plane these are the
same
okay and notice that it the
you can calculate exactly the degrees
here it's Q Plus one regular and so it's
not a sparse graph but it's a very good
expander actually
okay
now let's look at the example for D
equals two
here I have uh F to the four and I have
three types of vertices lines planes and
three spaces
picked up
and my
faces or triple Z1 contained in U2
contained in u3 now already now notice
that I don't have the same number of
lines as I do the number of planes
there's many more planes in F to the
four okay so the complex is not going to
be regular anymore right the degree of a
Vertex U1 is going to be uh go oops
going going here is going to be much
larger than the degree going down
and okay that's okay so let's look at
the links of this complex okay first
let's fix some element U2 some plane and
let's look at the link
of this guy
so the vertices are all the U ones that
are contained in this U2 and all the u3s
that contain this plane
okay and the nice thing about this link
is that every line that is contained in
YouTube
is also contained in every u3 that
contains U2
so you get your complete bipartite graph
okay so that's obviously a very good
expander if you're asking yourself are
the links good expanders this link is is
very good
what about if we take a Vertex U1 so not
all the links in this complex are the
same it turns out if I start from a
Vertex U1 and I look at its link
I don't know it just keeps happening
then I get all the all the planes that
contain this line and also all the three
spaces that contain this line and the
graph between them is again the plane
three-space incidence graph but since
they all contain a line you can kind of
take a quotient and you get a graph that
isomorphic to the graph from D equals
one it's really just again the lines
versus planes incidence graph
and as I said before this is actually a
very good expander so all the links in
this two-dimensional context are very
good expanders and you can go on and see
that for Dimension D you can recursively
see that the links are always kind of
combinations of complete apartheid
graphs with the lower dimensional
spherical buildings so this is a very
good expander
final example
I'm not going to describe the complexes
it's uh beyond my ability
but let me just tell you abstractly what
I know about them
so for every integer d
and for every Prime power Q you have a
family an infinite family of D
dimensional complexes
such that the number of the vertices in
these complexes goes to Infinity
but in each one of these complexes for
every vertex the link of this vertex is
just the D minus one dimensional
spherical
well
okay can you hear me multiple times or
once
multiple
foreign
sorry about that
uh
okay so
um I just said that we have this
infinite family of complexes where the
links are exactly the spherical
buildings in particular spherical
building only depends on q and d so it's
fixed size and and the number of
vertices goes to Infinity so you have
your uh family of connected
complexes
Dimension D in constant degree and yet
all the links
are very good expanders because the
links are themselves these spherical
buildings
um
it's not hard to see that they're very
good expanders
so really kind of
the way this Theory started is by
looking at these objects and realizing
that you can prove a lot of interesting
things about them just by understanding
the links and you don't uh you don't
need to understand like the complete
picture and this is really the power of
these uh these objects that they have
this a local to Global Feature A lot of
times in the complexity we want to
understand some you know NP hard
problems some CSP or some global object
by and we don't know how to
get a handle on the entire thing so
sometimes good to look at small pieces
and the links are is nice little pieces
that kind of give information
and here is an ethereum that is a kind
of a first manifestation of this
phenomena this local to Global
phenomenon that says if you know
something about the links you can do
something globally about the entire
complex
and
[Music]
um
this is the trickling down theorem of
oppenheim
uh what does it say it says the
following if you have a complex X and
let me start by just looking at a
two-dimensional context but really this
goes to D dimensions and so you have a
two-dimensional complex
and about the graphs the graph
underlying the context you don't know
that it's an expander or anything all
you know is that it's connected
but you do know that for every vertex
the link of this vertex is actually a
good Lambda expander Lambda link
expander okay so you know that the graph
is connected and you know that the links
are good expanders the conclusion is
that the entire graph is a good expander
and how good it's Lambda divided by one
minus Lambda so if Lambda is very small
goes goes to zero then mu is almost as
small as Lambda very small as well if
Lambda is half or above you don't get
anything here
okay
and just by iteratively applying this
you can get the same theorem for not a
two-dimensional complex but for a d
dimensional complex just by first
applying it from the D minus two links
to the D minus three links and then to
the D minus four links and kind of
trickling down this theorem until you
deduce the entire graph is a an expander
okay but I think it's already impressive
enough to see this theorem for Dimension
D equals two so suppose you have a graph
that has a bunch of triangles and every
vertex touches maybe even a constant
number of edges but you know they're
around every vertex if you look at the
sub graph induced by the the sub graph
of the link you know that it's a Lambda
expander now sometimes people ask what
do you mean a good expander if every
vertex is a constant number of vertices
Neighbors
how is it defined to be a good or not a
good expander well it is defined right
we said that a graph is an expander if
the normalized second largest eigenvalue
is
bounded by Lambda this is defined for a
graph even on 20 vertices you don't have
to have a growing family
so that's what we mean by Lambda
expander
and let's see
why this theorem is true or let's say a
proof of this theorem
okay so let's start we have a an
adjacency operator a associated with the
global graph
okay and let's take some eigenfunction
of this of this a okay and suppose it
has eigenvalue gamma okay since we
already assumed that X is connected
we know that this gamma is smaller
strictly smaller than one but it could
be like one minus one over n and our
goal is to prove that gamma is actually
much smaller
okay so let's take this eigen function
we know that it's orthogonal to the all
ones by the way I'm going to assume that
you know my graph is regular and my
complexes are regular because it makes
things easy but if you've seen these
things before you can you can see that
uh when I write expectation there is an
appropriate choice of probability
distribution that you don't need this
assumption if you choose the
distribution correctly then this works
also for a irregular complexes
okay so we have our eigen function f and
we write we start writing this quadratic
form gamma equals the inner product of f
with AF
okay which is just the expectation over
all possible edges
of f of U times F of w
okay for all edges in the graph now this
is a a key a key step
the expectation over a random Edge in a
graph in this graph can be decomposed
into like a convex combination of
small
expectations as follows when you choose
a random Edge UW it's the same as if you
first choose a random vertex V
and then you look at the link of v and
you choose a random Edge in the liquid
why is this the same
because really what's going on is that
you can think of it you're choosing a
random triangle in the complex uvw
and then you choose which pair to put as
the edge in which vertex to put as the V
so you choose V randomly out of the
three possibilities and then the other
two are the random Edge so you basically
chose a random triangle and then a
random Edge in it this is the same as
just to choosing a random Edge that's
exactly how we Define these
distributions
uh in the case where the graph is
completely regular you just get uniform
and if the graph is not completely
regular this is exactly how you define
the distribution to make the theorem
work
this theorem and many other theorems and
so we get this equality that the
expectation over a random Edge is the
same as first choosing random vertex and
then taking expectation only over the
edges inside the link
okay now once we have this equality we
can use stuff that we know about the
links so we have gamma
equal to this expectation expectation
over V and then expectation of something
that's going on inside the link of this
and so we can even to emphasize we can
Define f superscript v to be a function
that's only defined on the vertices that
are neighbors of v and it's just the
same as f f v of U is f of U
and we can denote a superscript v to be
the adjacency operator on the link
and this is the promise that we had what
are we trying to prove we are given a
complex we know that for every link a
sub V is a very good expander and we
want to prove that the entire operator a
is a good expander okay so we're now
going to be able to use the fact that a
sub V is a very good expander we just
write this inner expectation as the
inner product of FV with AV of f of V
and then we just uh want to use the
spectral bound but you know it's it's
best to shift F of v f of B does not
have expectation zero so we shift it to
G of V what is gfv it's F of V minus the
expectation of fle Okay g of V is a
function that has expectation zero
inside the link
and by the way what is the expectation
of f of V
you look at the vertex V you look at all
of its neighbors all the U's that
neighbor it and you take the expectation
there this is exactly what the operator
a does when you apply a on F and look at
Point V you just take the expectation
over the neighbors of V of f of V
so you get AF of V but F was assumed to
be an eigen function with eigenvalue
gamma so AF at Point V equals gamma F at
0.3 so that's why we have here
that the expectation of f is equal to
gamma times F of E
okay
so now we can use the fact that AV
itself is a good expander to get this
upper bound that on one hand you have
here the expectation of f of V which we
already know now is gamma of f of V but
squared this is like the remember when
we said that an expanders is when AV is
like the J like the complete graph
operator so this is the term you get
from from J and then this is the error
term this bound is a
Lambda times the norm of GV squared
and now all we have to do is take these
values take expectation over V and see
what we got
so uh I guess I have here G of V Okay g
of V squared this is Pythagoras Theorem
GV squared plus this constant thing this
is like the constant function which is
orthogonal to GV the sum of these
squares equals this Square
so you get this equation you take
expectation over V
and what you get is well
um this is just the expectation of f
squared which we assumed is one
and this is again the expectation of f
squared which we assume this one so you
get 1 minus gamma squared
okay so all in all we got that gamma on
this side is less than
1 minus gamma squared okay so sorry
times Lambda I forgot to Lambda okay so
here I need to add a Lambda
Okay so
um okay anyway this is what we get gamma
is less than gamma squared plus Lambda
times 1 minus gamma squared and when you
um when you rearrange it you get the
required result so
um
one way to understand this proof is that
I think the key step is that we managed
to break the expectation over
a typical edge here in the
in the center to a bunch of local
expectations and then we managed to use
the knowledge that we had about the
links
and that's how kind of the expansion in
the links was strong enough to force
Global expansion I think it's quite
quite remarkable
okay
now I want to move on to talk about a
random walks on a
simplicial complexes and the up and down
operators
maybe if there's any questions before I
continue
okay
so when we think about random walks in
graphs
we think of going from a Vertex to a
neighbor to a neighbor and so on when we
have a higher dimensional complex like
we do here we can walk on the vertices
like we did before but we can also walk
on the edges for example we can walk
from Edge
to vertex to another Edge and so on we
can also walk from Edge to Triangle to
another Edge and so on and these works
are not the same right if if I take the
walk from Edge to Triangle to Edge then
if I start from this Edge and I go to
this triangle and then I go to this Edge
then I go to this triangle then I go to
this Edge I kind of get stuck in this
component I'll never be able to move
from this Edge to this Edge
right so the the random walk when I go
from Edge to Triangle to Edge in this
specific complex has two different
components whereas the random Mark that
goes from Edge to vertex to Edge to
vertex to Edge to vertex to Edge
actually manages to transverse between
all of the edges in this graph
so these two random marks on the edges
one going two triangles and back down
one going to vertices and back up
have different Behavior and actually the
reason for this is the link of this
vertex which is a disconnected link is
kind of to blame for the fact that the
lower walk in the upper walk they are
not don't have the same connectivity I'm
not going to go into these details too
much but you can show that if all the
links are connected in in all the
dimensions then the upper walk and the
lower walk will will have the same
connectivity
and okay
so one way to think about the random
works is to draw out the simplicial
complex in layer form so you put like a
a blob of vertices for the vertices so
you'll have one dot for every vertex and
then you'll put another blob of
vertices or points let me say points one
for every Edge
and then another blob one for every two
phase and so on you can have more and
more layers and you can think of
connecting between say a triangle and an
edge just if the triangle contains this
Edge
okay so then the random walk that goes
from Edge to Triangle to Edge is like a
random walk in this Viper take graph
where you go like this
okay and so you can already see that the
connectivity of going from Edge to
Triangle to Edge is the same as the
connectivity of going from triangle to
Edge to Triangle so these two have the
same connectivity and also the same
expansion if you think of like the rate
of convergence of this random walk they
will have related expansion whereas the
random walk that goes from Edge to
vertex to Edge to vertex to Edge this
way is not exactly the same as the
random app that goes from
Edge to Triangle to Edge to Triangle
this way these at least superficially
they look different
and our definition of when is complex a
good random work expander will actually
compare these two
uh these two random walks okay so let's
set up some notation we Define CI
the set of code chains at level I just
to be all the functions from the I faces
to real value numbers
uh there's a whole other theory that
deals with the kind of linear algebra on
a high dimensional expanders it's not a
whole other Theory it's a whole other
part of this Theory and then you just
replace the coefficients R by say F2 for
example and I'll say a couple of things
about that later on but for now let's
see I just be all the real valued
functions on x i and we Define an inner
product between two functions to be
the natural thing you have some
distribution over the faces in x i and
you take expectation of f
at Point s times F Prime and point s
okay and we also add the for convenience
we also add this extra
-1 Dimension layer which just has the
empty set
okay now we come to the definition of
the up and down operators so it's a very
natural
definition the app operator takes me
from I chains so functions on the I
faces two functions on the I plus one
faces so moves me one dimension up
and how is it defined it's actually
defined by looking down so if I have an
i chain F and I chain is a function on I
faces and I want to evaluate it at a
point s what I do is I look at all the
subfaces of s t
and this notation T less than S just
means the t is contained in s and oops
and it has one dimension below okay so
for example if s is a triangle then T is
all the three edges inside this
okay so the app operator at the point s
averages F of t on all the faces just
one below so in particular if I want to
Define I have a function on the edges
and I want to define the up of this
function to be a function on the
triangles then for every triangle I just
average the value on the three
edges and this will be my new function
U of f
defined on all the triangles and
similarly the down operator it takes me
from an i chain to an i minus 1 chain
now I do the reverse operation if I want
to know what DF evaluates to at a point
S I need to look at all the faces T
there are just one above this so if I
want to know what DF is at some vertex
say you know four
in my function f was on the edges then I
just average the four values given here
and notice that the way I wrote it I
wrote expectation and I'm kind of hiding
the distribution so there is a proper
way to define distribution over the eye
faces and it's always going to be with
respect to that distribution and
if you're a beginner to this area then
the best thing is to think that the
complex is super regular so that every
Edge is contained in exactly the same
number of triangles and every triangle
is contained in exactly the same number
of four three faces and so on and so on
so then all these distributions are
uniform
okay and it's kind of almost obvious to
see from the picture
that up and down operators are actually
transposed of one another
join to one another if you have a
function a co-chain
in CI and another one in CI plus one
then the inner product of f with DG
is equal to the inner product of
UF with G so basically you can move D to
this side and make it into a u
okay and the reason is that what what
does this equal this whole thing it
really equals to the expectation over
choose face s and then choose all
possible ways to choose T just above it
an average F of s times G of t
okay alternatively you can first choose
T randomly and then choose it has to be
some face just below it and write G of T
times F of s and that will be
the first will be this equality this
quantity in the second will be this
quantity so these two are really a joint
okay so now when you have this
object this combinatorial object
and you want a to
understand various combinatorial
properties of the expansion of sets or
whatnot it's very convenient that we
know to have a good basis like a Fourier
kind of basis a good basis that respects
or works well with these natural up and
down operators and the max will talk
about this in more details and later on
[Music]
um
we will first study the high order
random walks now that we Define the up
and down operators so we've talked
before about the lower random walk going
from
I face it from I chains
to I chains by going first down and then
going up so
say you have a function you you started
in Edge you go to a random vertex and
then you go to another Edge
okay that's going first down and then
back up
so we view this as the lower random walk
and the other operator is the one that
goes
starts from an eye chain first goes up
to a triangle and then back down back to
an edge this is called the upper random
walk so let's look what this these two
random walks look like in the case of I
equals zero when we have functions on
the vertices this is the most familiar
case when we look at graphs we have a
function on the vertices of the graph
and let's look at what do these two
random marks
behave like so first let's do the down
up operator you first apply down on your
function and then you apply up
okay and I only write the always the
index I tells you on what dimension of a
code chains you're operating so UI
operates on CI di plus 1 operates on CI
plus one
okay so UD 0 operates on C zero so it's
on functions on the vertices so
basically I started the vertex and now
I'm supposed to go down well if I'm at
the vertex how can I go down I can go
down to the empty set
okay so if I scroll up here you can see
it in this picture
um
we added this empty set layer that
allows us to go down even from vertices
and every vertex when you go down from
it you just go to the empty set so when
you go down and then back up you're
basically going to any other random
vertex
okay so going back here
so really this operator
it starts from some vertex
V and it goes down to the empty set and
then back up to any other vertex with
uniform probability this is exactly what
the J
the all ones Matrix does I guess it
maybe I should have written a one over n
to the normalized
yeah J
and okay so that's the down up operator
what about the up down operator the up
down operator okay I'm starting from a
Vertex I go up to one of the edges
containing it
and okay so suppose I go up to this Edge
and now I go down so I can go down
either to four or two three
so with probability half I actually go
back to where I started that's this part
and with probability half
I go to a random neighbor
do you see that because no matter which
Edge I chose there's always going to be
probability half of going back to where
I started so that's this component and
there's going to be probability have to
go to some random neighbor
okay so the up down the upper random
walk is not really the random look we
were hoping to get it's a lazy version
it's lazy with probability half it stays
in place but really half it goes to
where we want it so if m is really the
random walk on the graph then the up
down is a is a lazy version of M
and when we defined what an expander is
and we said an expander is a graph where
the adjacency oops The adjacency Matrix
of this graph is a good approximation of
the complete graph
we wanted to really compare these two
and we don't we don't need this extra
laziness so we introduce this notation
Mi plus this is the non-lazy upper
random walk
and it's defined to be the up down
operator
when we remove the laziness from it
okay so really uh
the way to to understand which constants
to choose here you want to have this
this equation satisfied let's let's look
at this equation
I want to express the up down walk as
some component of laziness this is the
one over I plus two times I
plus another component which is the the
non-lazy part
okay so when I kind of rearrange it I
get this formula okay let's check it for
I equals zero for I equals zero I get
here
half and here half
and m0 plus the non-lazy upper walk is
exactly the work that goes from vertex
what did I do from a vertex
two random Edge containing it and then
to a random vertex in this Edge except
you're not allowed to go back so you
must go here so it's really just a
random walk on the graph
okay so mi Plus in the case of I equals
zero is really the adjacency Matrix of
the graph and so
I could have defined a
for a graph not for high dimensional a
complex for a graph I could have said a
graph is a Lambda expander if
this holds
the down up work which for case of
graphs is just this normalized J Matrix
the difference between Mi plus and the
down up walk is at most elando gamma
here so again for a graph Mi plus is
just the adjacency Matrix this guy is
Just J maybe n actually add this so This
is Just J this is sorry no
this is just m this is just J
again a graph
so now we give this definition which is
really just a another you describe it
this way you see that this definition is
just the generalization to higher
dimensions of the definition for graphs
really what you want is now to say okay
I'm gonna call my complex High
dimensional expander with respect to
random walks or random walk expander if
you will if for every level I the
difference between the down up walk the
lower work and the upper walk is small
well that's not quite precise because
the lower walk doesn't have noticeable
laziness but the upper walk is kind of
forced to have this laziness right if
you walk from an edge to a triangle back
to an edge there's probability one-third
that you'll go back to where you started
so you're always going to experience
this laziness so we're gonna remove the
laziness component this is why we add
the Plus in the notation
no it's not why I wanted to pass the
plus is for upper but anyway this is The
annotation for the non-lazy and and once
you look at this M plus rather than the
down up
I could have written here d u minus UD
that
would cost me this extra laziness so
instead I removed the laziness and use
the the non-lazy random work and we
Define a random walk expander to have
this difference being very small okay
and we have a one-sided version where
the norm is bound in absolute value by
gamma and we have a two-sided sorry
that's a two-sided and the one sided
version is where you say that these are
in semi-definite order in PSD order
dominated by gamma times the identity
okay so this is a definition and we have
a a theory a theorem that says that the
link expander definition
implies the random walk definition
and also
to some extent vice versa although you
do lose parameters vice versa says that
if you satisfy the random work
definition you have a good comparison
between the upper and lower random works
then you must also satisfy the link
definition
okay so qualitatively these two
definitions are
yeah I I I'm about to finish uh
qualitatively these two definitions are
the same
um and okay after the break we will talk
more about this actually maybe do you
want me to okay allow some questions
before we take a break
any questions
so this definition of Lambda run work
expander does it imply like a
fast-mixing for the up down walk or down
upward
does it imply what for the up down walk
I like it like a fast mixing for the
Uptown or down on top walk oh yeah
definitely thanks for the question yes
actually it what is it implies is that
the spectral profile of the up down walk
uh is very similar up to errors that are
comparable to gamma
to the Spectra to the behavior of random
walks on the complete complex
so in some sense this allows us to say
that if you're a gamma expander in gamma
is you can think of it as very small
then random walks mix
more than that they mix at a pace which
is just like the best place you can opt
for which is in the the complete complex
okay so you know for graphs we said when
is the next when is a graphene expander
if it's a good approximation to the
complete graph
it would be natural maybe more natural a
priority to say okay we're going to
define the same thing for higher
Dimensions we're going to say complex is
a good expander if it's a good expect
approximation to the complete
say two-dimensional complex if we were
in Two Dimensions but how can we even
Define it if a complex has much fewer
edges than n choose two how can you even
compare an operator that works on Space
of edges
that here you have few edges and here
you have many edges there's no good way
to to write this comparison
and this is a way to circumvent it you
say no no I'm going to compare for the
complex the upper and the lower and the
marks of that complex
and I know that for the complete complex
I have very good comparison actually
maybe we should have checked it for the
complete complex these two random marks
once you remove the laziness they're
identical okay so you get zero in your
gamma is really zero
for our complex okay it's not zero it's
some gamma but somehow this allows you
to to show that the random wax mix just
almost as fast as in the complete
complex thanks for the question
any more quick questions before we take
a break
Okay cool so we'll take a break of 30
minutes and come back so thank you
[Applause]
thank you
foreign